[Music]
oh
man
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is this the best simply because we
said so this is the show that my
brothers and i wish that we had when we
were learning about business investing
and finance i am here with two of my
brothers joe and john
how do you know their names are joe and
john real simple their names are on the
back of their chairs this weekend was a
really big weekend for joe joe is now
off the market he is uh engaged
congratulations i just want to start off
the show a little congratulations thanks
and clapping for yourself okay hey uh
were you nervous slightly yeah slightly
did you execute correctly executed great
did she say yes yeah well yes okay just
making sure all of those three important
parts
oh we have a little photo here by the
way great form great form nice uh
upright back nice uh 90 degree angle on
both knees i think i uh uh might have
creased the toe box a little bit on the
shoe in the back but we'll be all right
your knee is touching the ground so you
are not running a fake yeah you're ready
to go right there yeah quad pretty uh
pretty good and yes that is me up in the
bushes
that is me right there so to be clear
can we just say first why i'm in the
bushes yeah go ahead no you go ahead
explain it okay so we got there and we
knew it's a saturday here in miami i
thought it was gonna be a little crowded
which it was uh so i said you're gonna
have to run up the stairs and i want
everyone cleared out we can't have
anyone walking down the stairs and good
thing you did because there's people
walking down the stairs big groups of
people right before we got there and you
cleared it out but then the picture's
hilarious because you're like in the
bushes trying to get a photo of yourself
i didn't want her to see i didn't want
her to see that i was filming and be
like why is he filming but why are you
filming there was
people on the ground filming listen in a
big moment of your life you can never
have too many camera angles you can
never make sure that you got it what
happens if you had trusted her sister to
record it and she had messed up
her sister took pictures oh so we're
good all right no i'm just saying that
picture right there is a pretty good
picture by the way you also
symmetrically lined it up so that the
center of the stairway is right behind
you as well
pretty good i ain't no dummy yeah john
what do you think
congrats
thanks john
you good john i'm great johnny and i got
another member of the union yeah she
wasn't already in the union
all right here we go make sure that
you're hitting the like button we got a
big show today we've got max kaiser
stacey herbert both coming on the show
they're gonna be here live in studio in
about 20 minutes or so and we got a lot
to talk about bitcoin el salvador etc on
top of that we also have a couple of
topics we're going to talk through first
though don't forget if you want any
merch go to thebestbusinessshow.com
go there we still have all the ugly
christmas sweaters up there we got the
trillionaire energy sweatshirt we have
various hats bitcoin 100k etc second
sofa.com pomp sofa has been a fantastic
partner so go to sofi.com when you go
there you can go ahead and open an
investment account that investment
account allows you to buy everything
from bitcoin to pre-ipo stocks to etfs
and regular individual stocks as well if
you go ahead you open an invest account
you put two thousand dollars into the
account you join the diamond hands club
if you don't have two thousand dollars
you can put a smaller amount and then
grow it into two thousand dollars once
you do that you'll be the diamond hens
club now why is the diamond hands club
so important because next tuesday we
have our next meeting every other
tuesday we meet and when we meet we jump
on sometimes we bring guests sometimes
we bring friends sometimes it's just us
but you get to interact with us you get
asked us questions about personal
finance education taxation uh
investments etc uh and this upcoming
tuesday we are going to bring a special
guest i'm not going to tell you who it
is yet but go open a sofa account so
fi.com you can join the diamond hands
club you can be there last tuesday there
was a financial advisor there so some of
it is financial advice
not from us but somebody else correct
correct correct all right make sure you
keep smashing the like button today
we're just going to start off real real
big if we get the 500 likes i'm gonna
give out 500 worth of bitcoin start the
week off right with 500 bitcoin to one
person when they go ahead and we get
over 500 likes make sure you hit that
like button
anything else you do want to add before
we get into some topics
let's get after it are you good i'm very
good yeah are you good i'm great i'm
always great johnny said he's gonna be
taking shots nope are you gonna take a
shot on the show today nope if max takes
one will you take one
sure
that wasn't very hard to convince you
all right over the weekend there was a
massive drawdown in bitcoin
cryptocurrency prices what the hell is
going on bitcoin went down more than 20
yes 20 in a single weekend and
previously it hit a haul a high of 69
000
nice of course bitcoin going to 69 000
there's a joke in there somewhere it
then drew all the way down on some
exchanges went below 40 000 most
exchanges around 42 000
and today sits about 48 000 this baby is
very volatile obviously in us dollar
terms but what we can see is why exactly
did this happen sam over at alameda had
a great tweet storm on this he said a
few features of this move were important
the price of bitcoin for instance was
nearing in on a long time local minimum
sub 53k hadn't happened since early
october the same day it cost fifty
thousand dollars it was late friday u.s
early weekend asia among the lowest
liquidity times the entire week he then
went on and said these line up for our
favorite effect liquidations cascades
tons of leveraged longs have been opened
in the past month nothing special just
what always happened in crypto in fact
the insane leverage is lower than it
used to be but the effect was still
substantial then he said part of the
reason it was still substantial was the
low liquidity on various exchanges
bitcoin got sub 30k for a moment and
that was because of how little liquidity
sits on the book during super off hours
the initial liquidations were the same
sizes as usual and then he finished with
but the bids they were getting market
ordered into were thinner because more
price impact and more liquidation since
the prices got really low in many cases
so what you can understand here is if
you don't understand how leverage works
is that people basically saw that there
was consolidation in the 50 000 uh area
for the price 53 54 55 000 per bitcoin a
bunch of people started to take out
leverage they wanted to go along with
leverage they thought the price was
going to go up and at the exact same
time there was tons of leverage in the
system then we also saw that somebody
went on to the order books and when
there was very thin liquidity in when it
was late friday uh night in the united
states and early weekend in asia they
went ahead and they were able to cause a
liquidation cascade basically the way
this works is that if you have leverage
and the price moves against you you then
are a force seller as you sell your
bitcoin the price continues lower then
the next person who's got leverage they
have to sell more and so in a very over
generalized way again very over
generalized manner the more people that
are levered along when the price moves
against them the faster and faster the
price goes down which is exactly what we
saw happen here
now as we saw december 4th at 12 33 a.m
this was in the heart of it will
clemente young wizard 1.79 billion
dollars of bitcoin long's liquidated in
the last hour so pretty incredible
amount of leverage getting wiped out in
a very swift move from bitcoin now when
we go ahead and we look we have a quote
from matt malley the equity strategist
at miller tavik he said quote it looks
like somebody likely got hit with a
margin call yesterday and thus was
forced to sell the bitcoin market tends
to be much more thin on the weekend so
that probably exasperated the decline
once the dust has settled the buyer came
back in and it stabilized pretty simple
lots of leverage price moves against you
four sellers price goes down quickly but
we've come back a little bit now where's
bitcoin headed from here we've got ed
moya the senior market analyst at onanda
he said bitcoin is in no man's land
right now and that does not seem to be
changing anytime soon the long-term
bullish case remain remains intact but
prices seem poised to consolidate
between fifty two thousand and sixty
thousand dollars so it's pretty crazy to
see people on wall street now all
talking about bitcoin as a tradable and
investable asset saying that the
long-term bullish case remains intact
but prices seem ready to consolidate one
when you guys woke up on saturday and
saw that the price had dropped
significantly what was your first
reaction well that was the day i was
gonna propose and i was not very happy
i was like damn today's the day y'all
gonna do this
uh but yeah i mean i i saw it and i
disappointing but you can obviously see
what's happening with the leverage and
everything like that so it's not totally
surprising i think some of this stuff
was to be expected once we saw people
kind of the amount of leverage they were
using in the prices that we were seeing
and they're right about kind of uh the
market being thin on the weekends and
then it bouncing back up i i'd be more
curious like what is your overall
thought on on retail people using
leverage in general
again i think leverage uh i think i
actually uh tweeted it on saturday
morning when i woke up i just said
leverage is a hell of a drug right and
that's my general uh sense about it is
just like any drug uh leverage uh can be
used to get high on right and it also
can be used to spiral out of control as
well so there's a lot of people who
forget that alcohol is a drug and if i
was to ask most people hey do you like
alcohol they're like yeah i love alcohol
i like the taste of it i like how i feel
when i drink i have fun when i'm
drinking et cetera that's great but in
uh kind of a
average amount drinking alcohol maybe
it's a little bit bad for you but
there's a trade-off because you enjoy
yourself or whatever and uh there's
great social uh kind of implications to
it and so you're willing to drink
because you enjoy it but if you are a
drunk 24 7 365 and you overdo it then
you could die right and so like the same
thing with leverage is that if you want
to use a little bit of leverage here and
there one you should know what you're
doing if you can't describe exactly how
leverage works if you don't do it uh and
have any experience like you probably
shouldn't do it right but also two is
too much of it can be deadly it can be
fatal right you can literally lose your
entire portfolio if you become
over-leveraged and so i don't think of
leverage as good or bad like in a binary
sense i think of it in terms of how much
leverage are you using and how
experienced are you in using this so if
you have no experience then you probably
shouldn't do it right and also if you're
experienced you're unlikely to go super
over levered uh but still you know
market is the market economic incentives
take over people are greedy and we get
highly leveraged situations because they
have high degree of certainty that price
is going higher and then you get these
moves this is like a like the mo of
bitcoin bitcoin loves to wipe out
levered longs like this and so guess
what you know what i do i literally just
stack sats and i just keep stacking and
stacking and stacking and we'll see what
happens
john what do you think
nothing new for bitcoin volatility it
works both ways the levered part of it
some apps like robinhood for example
when you do calls or puts as a retail
trader i believe you have to actually
deposit the amount of money that you
could get um you could have to pay right
so they kind of stopped that from
going way outside your spectrum but
almost incurring a lot of debt which i
actually do like because it stops those
retail traders from getting involved in
that i saw this on friday night will's
of beast for tweeting this at 12 30 a.m
crypto market does not sleep right 24 7
365 days a year
wall street would not be able to keep up
with this in my opinion um and look yeah
it's nothing new volatility down 20 from
uh friday's close it kind of had that
draw down into saturday and then we were
as of this morning 10 from friday's
close we were down
it's not uh well it's not concerning but
it also makes you think don't check the
price too much yeah and i was just gonna
say right anyone that uh is buying
bitcoin for the day-to-day movements
trying to make money like if that's your
game and you're good at it sure go for
it but i think myself for sure and other
people a lot of other people uh watching
this show do it because they have a long
time horizon right which is the greatest
advantage you can find of saying hey i'm
not going to care about the the
short-term price for the next five years
10 years whatever it might be you're
putting in money that you're hoping uh
you believe in the asset you believe in
the technology you believe in the future
of it right so you're saying hey this
will appreciate dramatically in five 10
15 years i'm not going to worry about
the day-to-day movements because when
you look at bitcoin's price historically
everyone knows yes it's been volatile
yes it has appreciated greatly over the
last decade but ultimately even in these
massive run-ups we've seen massive
drawdowns so in 2017 i believe the
number was four to five times during
that bull run uh when i went from about
3 000 to 20 000 we saw drawdowns of 30
or more four times right so this is not
anything new from a uh end of the bull
run cycle like we don't necessarily know
what that means i think that this is
more common than people would assume
based off of kind of historical price
movements but ultimately like i said
like if you can just zoom out for a
minute and not care about hey what's
happening every day and just turn the
computer off don't look at the price
don't do all that kind of stuff history
has proven that you're going to be much
better off than kind of worrying about
that day-to-day movement panic selling
getting emotional about things and it's
much better to just have a long time
horizon
over the weekend it was the sixth time
bitcoin went down more than 20
it was the third time that bitcoin went
down more than 30 percent this current
drawdown right and depending on what
exchange you looked at in some cases
went down more than 40 percent it'd be
the second time it did that and remember
over the summer there was a 50 plus
drawdown so
volatility is literally the name of the
game when it comes to bitcoin just chill
out just everyone just relax
in 2019 the top four banks made over
eight billion dollars in overdraft fees
that's right an overdraft fee means you
don't have money in your account so the
top four banks took eight billion
dollars from people who had no money in
their accounts pretty damn insane now
what we do know is that capital one has
come out and they said that they are
going to drop all of their overdraft
fees this will cost them about 150
million dollars per year in revenue but
capital one trying to better service the
customer is saying that they will no
longer charge overdraft fees so when you
start to look at this the customers that
can spend more than they have that
ultimately leads to these overdraft fees
and so you can see here that these
overdraft fee revenue charts were
getting worse and worse and worse up
until 2020. went from 11.2 billion all
the way up to 12 billion in 2019 of
which eight billion dollars came from
the top four banks which pretty damn
crazy and so capital one is one of the
largest u.s banks to get rid of
overdraft fees they have over 350
physical locations and 70 000 atms what
they are going to do moving forward is
place all their customers who have paid
over drafts into a fee draft protection
service next year and it will also
decline transactions for customers with
overdraft protection so ultimately this
ends up being a pretty positive thing i
think for the end user is that the bank
will no longer take money from you if
you don't have the money now i first
heard about this problem about three
years ago and when i heard about it was
because there was somebody who was
pitching it to me they were starting a
company called bridget b-r-i-g-i-t
and when they started the company
bridget what they were telling me is
that these banks take all this money but
the reason why most people actually hit
the overdraft is not because they do not
have the money it's because there's one
of two things either you use the wrong
card and there's money in another
account and you got confused or two is
that you get paid on the 1st and the
15th of the month on the 12th you went
grocery shopping on the 13th your
netflix bill hit on the 14th you went
you made an outsized purchase you went
shopping or something bam you get with
your overdraft fee and then on the 15th
you get paid you actually have the money
on the 15th but you simply mismanaged
your money and your bank account and the
spending that you are doing and so what
they ultimately do
is you can go to
hellobridget.com and you can get a loan
from them it's an interest-free loan
they deposit 250 into your account as
overdraft protection it's pretty damn
cool thing and so ultimately i think
that one you see technology companies
trying to solve these problems saying
listen we know that there is bad stuff
that the banks are doing to their
customers we're going to build an entire
company all around protecting you from
these bad situations but also over time
what we're going to see is for banks to
be competitive they're going to have to
get rid of things like overdraft fees as
well and so i don't know how long it'll
take to get the very large businesses
and banks to do it but i do think the
writings on the wall those overdraft
fees over time will go away and there'll
be a loss of 12 billion dollars of
annual revenue for the banking industry
are we surprised john in terms of how
much money the banks take from people
with overdraft fees i'm not people tend
to spend more than they have and more
than they make a lot of the time as
average americans do 150 million dollars
into access out of a product or service
that you offer is a little crazy in my
mind um because unfortunately it is
their right to charge you that because
you signed up for the card or the
account um and they have the right to
charge you that they make 12 billion
dollars all u.s banks off over draft
fees alone so that is a lot of money
it's a major part of their business so
it's surprising to me that they asked it
only because they make so much money off
of it but i think it's great for
consumers i'm curious what they did on
their analytics side to see
hey like is it worth us at access like
are we gonna get enough customers and
make more money on other avenue revenue
revenue avenues um for that to make
sense
and i think it's interesting because
uh people look at these things as like a
race to the bottom right and when you
think about in those terms yeah everyone
is fighting for customers so there's
some legitimacy that comes to dropping
these fees and trying to win over
customers we sell the same thing with
brokerage accounts right the zero fee
commissions on equity trades zero fees
on all these different things right and
it was just a race to zero to try to
acquire customers and once one person
does it they essentially all have to do
it to compete but ultimately part of it
is competing against other banks but
part of it's also competing against the
new financial system right and saying
hey look there's all these new services
that are popping up there's uh there's
d5 there's crypto there's bitcoin
there's all this stuff and we have to
compete against a whole new set of
assets a whole new network of technology
and all this stuff so
sure you're competing against other
traditional banks but you're also
competing against a whole instructor now
which i think this is really just step
one the overdraft fees is the most
obvious thing it's like hey why are you
penalizing me for this when something as
simple as the the scenario you described
earlier could be happening and someone's
getting charged 30 35 or whatever it
might be and then there's companies like
strike who can literally if you're if
you're an employer you can pay your
workforce simultaneously all throughout
the day literally all throughout the day
and you can stream them a payment every
five minutes every 10 minutes every hour
to every day every two days every three
days whatever you want however you want
to pay your team and what it'll do is
it'll it would essentially eliminate
these overdraft fees if everyone's doing
that anyways because a lot of this just
comes down to getting paid on the 1st
and the 15th like traditional employers
do which makes absolutely zero sense in
the grand scheme of hey it's great for
accounting but if you have the
technology that wipes away all of that
uh the inefficiencies why wouldn't you
do that and i think a lot of employers
would choose to do that so steps like
this are logical in my in my point and i
think it's only a matter of time before
essentially every bank does this yeah i
i would love to see people start getting
paid on a normal basis at the end of
each day or at the end of each week
rather than waiting two weeks or by by
month so a couple of things one is
there's banks that do really nasty stuff
one of the things that the banks do is
they will literally say okay you swiped
your card three times today the third
one is when you actually overdraft but
what they'll do is they'll reroute the
transactions you know it's like
processing they'll reroute it so that
you overdraft on the first one and then
that means that the second and third one
overdraft as well so it goes from a 35
overdraft feat so now they get you three
times right so real nasty stuff the
second thing is that um on uh also uh is
that when the banks are um doing some of
this stuff uh people don't even realize
it they just
bake it into their expenses on a monthly
basis right so you end up getting this
like very weird world where it's it's oh
there's just fees that i get at the end
of each month it's 100 bucks and so that
just ends up being another hundred
dollars that i pay and people don't
realize exactly why it's happening or
moving money and stuff so it's just real
nasty uh nasty stuff that i don't
necessarily agree with all right well i
was going to say the other thing too is
like a lot of people think of it just as
30 35 but there's a good portion of
people this really hurts right because
the idea is if you don't have enough
money in your account to cover something
else you probably don't have enough
money to cover the 30 transaction fee or
the 35 overdraft fee so i think at the
end of the day like these fees they're
hurting the people that have the most
trouble with it right and you're just
charging them another fee on top of it i
understand why banks think they had the
reason or the right to do it but
ultimately it's gonna be a race to zero
and all these people are gonna go
compete for customers and they're gonna
have to lower their fees to essentially
zero i think we'll see all banks take
away over jeff fees in the next few
decades yeah i agree
all right which cost over 500 likes you
know what that means
just drop your twitter or your instagram
handle into the
chat and john's gonna pick one person
get 500 worth of bitcoin so drop your
twitter or your instagram handle into
the chat john will pick one person 500
bitcoin for free
recently facebook decided to unban
crypto ads what does that mean facebook
and a number of other social media or
media properties previously banned the
use of their advertising services for
crypto related companies their thought
process at the time was they couldn't
tell the difference between the good
actors and the bad actors so they just
simply said we're not gonna allow
anybody from this industry to advertise
on our platform obviously that's a loss
of revenue for them but also that was a
big big obstacle for a number of
companies in the space that were trying
to acquire users whether you're an
exchange a wallet provider some sort of
custodian or other type of service there
was a obstacle because you couldn't use
facebook one of the largest platforms in
the world to advertise also google and
others but now facebook has decided to
go ahead and unban this they were
reversing that long-standing policy they
previously said advertisers could submit
an application and include information
including any licenses they obtained
whether they were traded on a public
stock exchange or other relevant public
background on their business going
forward the company is expanding the
number of regulatory licenses it accepts
from 20 uh 227 from three and facebook
will continue to reject cryptocurrency
ads from companies that do not submit
one of the 27 regulatory licenses the
company is now accepting and so when we
start to think about this this is
ultimately going to lead to a big boom
in facebook's ad revenue you are going
to have to get some sort of license in
order to be able to participate but that
regulatory license is going to end up
being pretty powerful now on top of that
we have the number of monthly active
facebook users worldwide as of the third
quarter in 2021 you can see they are now
closing in on three billion people
around the world that use facebook's
platform so how do you guys think about
facebook doing uh the ads and allowing
this it seems to me like this is an
absolute no-brainer in terms of turning
this on as long as they can get away uh
from like a regulatory standpoint of not
uh facilitating scams or any of the
nonsense well that's the tough stuff
right is the scam part where you can't
really control some of those things and
if we've seen with facebook they love to
get kind of in the in the nitty-gritty
when it comes to controlling the message
and the narrative around uh different
advertisers or what they'll call
misinformation or uh different things so
it's actually surprising that it took
this long i would have expected them to
do this a while ago because what we've
seen is uh these assets and these
advertisers are good for business
they're gonna make a ton of money on
this stuff so i'm surprised it didn't
happen quicker
john
would you go run an ad on facebook for
uh one of these platforms
absolutely facebook has a massive
audience all around the world globally
um i think their
uh their users in india would be like
the third most popular country in the
world just based off the users that they
have india right so the reach that
facebook has is insane uh their ability
to keep people on the platform and
engage with the ads has been very
successful for a lot of consumer goods
and other services so i it's not
surprising to me at all um and they like
they've been a ford thinking company for
a very long time right they went to meta
they've done a lot of stuff they use
messenger um so i hope that they can
incorporate it into that but um i like
how they have some rules around who can
uh advertise there because you want
reputable companies
advertising you don't want your
reputable companies advertising on their
platform because it not only gives them
a bad name it gives the industry a bad
name as well yeah i agree with that all
right who's the winner for the 500
giveaway the winner is
melissa
del
goddillo
delgadillo yep you again dillo
100
[Music]
all right
a very special treat for everyone we
have max and stacy both here in studio
how are how are both of them
great john
y'all getting married i see
well i mean when did you two get when
did you two get married uh about
one year was it
we're off to a fast start
hey i brought a business jacket because
i thought this was the best business
show but everybody here is in like
t-shirts and sweatshirts so
i was deceived it was false advertising
well it's not a business show well here
here's the uh the whole key to it is
that most people go on business shows
and they feel like the clothes they wear
signal more about their intelligence
than the ideas they bring sure right but
you two show up and i'm like oh they got
great clothes and great ideas so it's
perfect yeah yeah there's also no pizza
in the pizza box
max and stacy got here a few minutes
early and i can see they've raided the
entire office that's good for food
you came for the swag all right what uh
what what have you two been up to i
wanted to see 2003 is when we met pomp
2003. he just
you remembered after that we got married
three times actually three times why
three times we just love each other so
much we like it no it's it was more like
a silver alert we weren't sure did we
get married already are we married
all right you guys recently went to el
salvador i want to start there yeah
and you've got the el salvador hat on
there yeah walk me through your
experience going to the country
well there you know since the early days
uh pomp we've been talking about the
potential for bitcoin
to be adopted by a country and become
legal tender to become a bitcoin citadel
or become a beacon for the world a new
expression of freedom for the world and
uh you know tour de meester was on my
show seven years ago we were talking
about this
and also a few other folks have been
talking about this no country yet has
pulled the trigger no one's had the the
the balls to do it yet uh so the
president buchelli just you know he said
you know what uh i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna make bitcoin legal tender so we
went there
and the place is uh being transformed by
by bitcoin so it started on bitcoin
beach
but that vibe is spreading everywhere
there's hope everywhere gdp in the
country looks like it's going to do they
had their best print uh since the early
90s you're like 10 this year probably a
lot higher next year
i'm going to go there we're going to go
there uh we're going to become citizens
there and
my my objective is to help transform
el salvador into the singapore of
central america so that means bringing
in
doing the startups looking at startups
we've been investing in bitcoin startups
since 2013.
looking at wealth management tools
investment banking
everything across the board because this
is going to be a it's just a huge growth
story um so everyone there was just
something it's a great town so
alzheimer's the beach town bitcoin beach
and i got my first surfing lesson
and i'll be needing some additional
surfing
[Laughter]
so with the waves the volcano the jungle
the energy the people
uh it's it's it's fantastic it's a
classic turnaround story it's it's a
it's an emerging market story um the
bitcoin bond is a huge part of that
story and this is a very exciting piece
piece of the puzzle okay so i want to
start first maybe you can talk about uh
the leadership right in terms of uh
somebody has to pull the trigger
somebody has to be the one to say okay
we're gonna do this
what's your read on buchelli the
government and like how important they
are to get it started and then how
important is it that they continue to
push this versus no once you get started
then the people kind of take over and
the government may not be as important
in the future
so
when we went to el zante
that's the only place i've ever been in
all these
years in bitcoin that is hyper
bitcoinized
so
it is
bitcoin
hyper bitcoinized and i think it was uh
from the bottom up i think
buchelli is a startup party
in a two-party country and
they won in a landslide they created
this party out of nowhere and um
you know started
this new revolution there and as max
said we interviewed tour de meester back
in 2014 february 2014 and max and tur
were speaking about this that which
would be the first country to hyper
bitcoin eyes and what they determined
was that it would be a small country
it would be a nimble country
and it would have economic freedom now
the economic freedom seems to be
following if you look at buchelli on
twitter if you look at him responding to
bitcoiners
when we went there for the uh bitcoin
conference le bitconf
there were uh for example some people
had problems because of the pcr tests
and all the um covid restrictions which
then he removed because all these
bitcoiners were complaining about it so
i think he seems to be responsive
to
the people
including now bitcoin because it's the
first hyper bitcoinized nation so
you know we always discuss the fact that
whenever like whenever we travel around
the world we feel like bitcoiners
first
and then american second and now
salvadoran you know
we feel bitcoiners and like
you've been there right like you know
how it is to be a bitcoiner right like
you feel so much more in common with a
bitcoiner than with any other
thing male
american you know whatever your new
yorker you know
you feel like a bitcoiner and and it
feels like a bitcoin nation now
i didn't you know there were some people
who were saying like oh he's uh forcing
this on to the population
but uh when you're in salvador
there weren't that many people that took
bitcoin so our hotel didn't the
restaurants didn't so we were um
free to not use bitcoin so nobody asked
for we we did ask a few places if they
accepted bitcoin but
elsante is hyper bitcoin eyes and it's
the first time i've ever actually had to
use
and been able to use lightning in the
real world it was lightning payments
everywhere everybody knew how to use it
down there
what was the
uh comparison to if you were you know
here in miami and you go to a coffee
shop you go to dinner et cetera and the
payment services versus there was it um
did it fulfill the promise i think that
a lot of people have of like it is
better or did you feel like there was
still some user experience kind of
snafus or obstacles or friction like
just talk to me about the actual
experience i did i didn't have any
snafu's like there was a guy riding his
little um moped sold us some papooses
and uh
just showed his phone paid for it and we
drove he drove off it was like instant
like that yeah there's the the chiva
wallet is uh it's okay there's a couple
of bugs with it but the other wallets
are now popular the moon wallet m-u-u-n
is very popular otherwise green wallet
uh so that's real on the ground
entrepreneurialism that's why i'm
excited a lot of startups you know i
think i can help create 50 60 jobs down
there right off the right off the bat
just uh bringing in some uh some some
money some capital some expertise uh get
some startups going they're already
going i'm just kind of plugging myself
into the volcano of energy that's going
on there and it's great to see buchelli
openly a troll and mock the imf on
twitter i mean i figured you would love
that like that's not a surprise it's
great i mean because the imf and and all
these global banks uh have really been
the bane of these countries in central
america and latin america explain why
like what is the relationship between
the imf and these countries and why do
you think that's been a problem well
central america latin america the u.s
has overthrown something like 15
countries in that region and it's always
been a colonial uh
backyard of the united states and so the
use of debt as a weapon has always been
the case if you read john perkins book
confessions of an economic hitman uh he
explains exactly how the u.s goes in
there and they load it up with debt and
they end up acquiring assets
and
there's been very little uh movement on
that in terms of how to escape u.s
colonial interests and so now with
bitcoin what's been recognized is that
it's a path out it's a vector out they
can have this unconfiscated censorship
proof money
that the imf can't get their dirty
little hands on and um their imf is
freaking out uh the central banks i
think are on notice now that the game is
up there's a new
sheriff in town and that is bitcoin
and so that's been the relationship
historically and i think uh oh another
great tweet was
from president buchelli
it was only three words
but it said
volumes
um somebody was trying to make the case
that you know you really shouldn't uh
piss off the imf and you know you guys
need to get right
and he only tweeted three words united
fruit company
now if you know the history you know
that the united fruit company which
later became chiquita banana was really
one of the first and the biggest u.s
corporations to come into the region
and essentially
overthrow the the government uh and for
the corporate interest of the united
states and so
the latin america like many countries
around the world they don't reap the
benefit of their local resources their
local commodities uh they are
client states of the us and u.s
corporations so here but kelly and you
say took somebody to really push it
through
who had to say you know what we're going
to do this uh he's a real entrepreneur
you know i liken him to george
washington you know george washington
had to actually
start a war you know to get a war going
to a lot of people in england hated
george washington
as an american i venerate george
washington uh during the american
revolution a third of the population
hated the idea another third of the
population was ambivalent maybe a third
of the population wanted to
establish uh a freedom from from the
empire the the english umpire
so uh but it took a band of rebels to do
it and they had the constitution of the
bill of rights with bitcoin the
constitution the bill of rights the
declaration of independence already
coded
into
the white paper it's already there all
you need is that white paper and you
effectively have everything you would
find in the constitution and the bill of
rights and what's amazing pop is that um
here you have a country smallish country
um
that
had because of the voluntary efforts of
open source developers around the world
the taproot upgrade
they didn't pay for that they didn't
have to worry about that their money got
upgraded overnight to uh taproot and now
they've got even better money than they
had when they started when they first
adopted bitcoin and that trend is going
to continue so they've got the hardest
money the best money they've got the
entrepreneurial spirit they've got the
resources they've got a great leader uh
that's why we're moving there that's why
we're becoming
you know salvadorian citizens that's why
i'm going to learn how to surf that's
why i'm uh
going to get a really nice tan dylan and
alsante
all right so talk to me about moving to
el salvador and getting the citizenship
one why are you moving why are you
getting the citizenship but also two how
does it actually work from a
kind of operational standpoint right so
um the volcano bonds that
was a big story um
what was an idea that was floated is
that similar to other countries that
offer citizenship economic citizenship
like um
in in in the um
bermuda and other countries bermuda st
kids same kids portugal they all do it
yep they have there's a different
programs out there so the idea was
floated hey you know put a hundred
thousand into these volcano bonds and
you're on the fast track to citizenship
or permanent residency so i tweeted that
you know i'm we're very interested in
this we would love to become
salvadorian citizens and
within a half hour we were getting
tweets back and feedback
back from the president and other people
in the government saying you know we'll
make you citizens um
asap you know by the end of this year uh
we'll get you we'll get you your
citizenship we we want entrepreneurs uh
we think you guys would be great
um kind of um
leading the pack in in
a whole wave of bitcoin immigrants who
are looking for
bitcoin city looking for a bitcoin
country um so i
i i think for me this is the biggest
thing since the genesis block you know
for me so it's been in this for 10 years
uh this is the most exciting thing i've
i've seen really in many many years and
i've always tried to be at the front of
the
the front of the you know the tip of the
spear or you know the really the the
edge of what's happening and i think
this is it so
that's what that's put all together and
packing our bags and going yeah would
you guys uh become uh salvadorian
citizens i would i'm curious like what
the uh what the response was from or the
vibe from like citizens down there are
they do they understand exactly what's
going on are they super excited about it
or they
looking to learn more just kind of your
guys thoughts on that
well my pitch to everybody is um
essentially here's unconfiscatable money
it's censorship proof money right and
everybody wants to have savings everyone
wants to have some store of wealth
everybody wants to build a nest egg
everyone wants to have a future
and the problem in these various
countries is that they've been dealing
with inflation and hyperinflation and
corruption
and so when you say look here's
money that you only you control and it's
the hardest money ever that just
immediately gets people's attention and
it's a real
it's a real uh need there's a need for
it where's in the u.s a lot of people
because this is a much different
situation it's more seen as a tech
project or it's a it's
something a fad or something and there's
no a lot of people here don't see it as
a as a real burning need
but except for maybe the uh you know i
was very early on
talking to the black community in
america you know if you look at isaiah
jackson's book bitcoin in black america
he mentions me in like the second page
and saying you heard about it with
kaiser report uh max kaiser a notable
white man
was uh you know um proselytizing bitcoin
and the black community in america is uh
the highest concentration of bitcoin
adoption in america for the simple
reason that's unconfiscatable wealth you
know this is a community that's had its
wealth confiscated over and over and
over again for you know 300 years right
so you say here's unconfiscatable wealth
those are the the two magic words and
it's like
all right i'm in
uh and so that's true all over the world
all over the world especially with the
us dollar gemini all over the world
inflation is now huge all over the world
and uh as an inflation protection as
many have explained it so brilliantly uh
bitcoin is par excellence really it's
nothing better what do you think
inflation do i'm assuming you don't
believe that it's actually 6.2 percent
and if you uh do or don't like how bad
can it actually get
well we've been talking about inflation
on kaiser report for a number of years
we've always said you have to look at
the rate of money printing or m1 or m3
and not look at the official numbers
because the official numbers have been
cooked for decades the hedonic
adjustments and all these other
things that are done to make it look
like inflation is low
is is you have to look past that and
look at the real
m3 m2 m1 money supply numbers and when
people started to figure that out they
stopped publishing m3
right because they don't want people to
know the rate at which money's being
printed but that's that's the rate at
which you should look at with inflation
now uh approximately 18 months ago
michael saylor came out with his famous
analogy of the melting ice cube and said
look we had a lot of money in our
balance sheet and it's losing 15 percent
of its of its purchasing power a year or
monetary energy as he likes to say uh
which is the real inflation number and
at the time the government was still
saying hey you know inflation is uh
whatever four or five percent they're
actually calling it deflation if you
recall they were calling inflation
deflation then they said oh it's
inflation it's transitory now it's
cyclical now it's forever
so
um the product the prognosis for
inflation
is that we've entered into a secular
inflationary period
where
you're going to see
um prices rise due to the excess of
money printing now for a number of years
uh
in america we haven't had an
inflationary depression really
outside of the revolutionary war in the
civil war if you remember the 30s was a
deflationary depression and in the 70s
it was stagflation this is just going to
be an inflationary depression like
weimar germany or
zimbabwe they're going to print
themselves and i can explain you know
that there's a structural problem here
uh why the interest rates are never
going to go up because over the past 20
or 30 years
you have this policy of extend and
pretend where all problems are
recapitalized refinanced new bonds are
floated
the debt keeps going high and higher but
the maturity rate on the debt gets
longer and longer so you have a duration
risk the 30-year treasury bond wasn't
even around when i was a stockbroker
back in the early 1980s so the problem
with that is that the entire complex of
debt structurally is incredibly
sensitive to any rise in rates
and that's so they're they're
like a paul volcker could not come in
raise rates and restore purchasing power
of the dollar that's off the table that
can't happen due to the structural
uh fragility of this bond market that
has incredible duration risk so we're
gonna they're only gonna there's only
one option and that is hyper hyper
printing from here
and when you think about that hyper
printing is it simply the game of
devalue the currency to pay off the debt
in the future with those devalued
currencies and so we can make a logical
argument why we should do it but
do they not understand what the impact
is or do they not have another choice so
they do understand it but they have no
other options they have to do it anyways
not to get overly political but
you know you do have a situation where
the people who benefit most from the
money printing the contillionaires a
term that we coined on the kaiser report
who get the money first and buy assets
and who make out like bandits
they're not uh unhappy with the money
that's being printed
uh simultaneously it would appear as
though there is a trend toward
reducing people's rights rights of
movement
right of communication
free speech
even in some places in europe for
example people are getting locked up
i don't think you can separate those two
i think this trend toward hyper printing
and locking people up it go together uh
because they don't want the blow back
they don't want to end up
like another reign of terror situation
where 35 000
french noblemen got beheaded by the
peasants who got tired of all the money
printing in the monarchy right so
they're they're aware of this they're
like wait a minute we don't want to do
that so let's just lock people up and
print all the money anyway so they're
they're out of control
basically i mean i don't think that's
that's that's a wild statement you know
i think that would be historically we've
seen this before and economically we see
this happening now and we also there's
nobody and who's in a position to write
policy that's making any intelligent
comments or choices about this at all i
haven't heard a single person make any
intelligent comments about what really
would need to be done
so when we think about the current
situation we've got six plus percent cpi
inflation we've got
four to four and a half percent
unemployment there's 11 million open
jobs in america um there are 80
of americans that are already being paid
over 15 an hour
and
we've got this public health crisis
which continues to fluctuate in terms of
i think the uh the uh
uh severity of the
public health crisis and which
areas in the country are or are not
worried about it uh which seems to be
bleeding into monetary fiscal policy how
do both of you think about
the current environment they're now
talking about tapering they're saying
that oh look we're going to actually
change this stacey you're smirking so
what what do you think is actually going
to happen here do you think that they
can taper at all they've been saying
that
for
five years six years that we've been
covering this on kaiser report and every
single time the headlines come out that
they're about to taper we always tell
people on kaiser report they're not
going to taper because you can't taper a
ponzi so we've said that for the last
six years uh they'll continue to say it
and it seems to work at least uh
temporarily you know to the markets
respond the dollar soars everybody
thinks oh the they're gonna taper for
real this time but they're never going
to
and um
how how can they how can they right like
we
there's more debt than ever so
they can never taper that ponzi scheme
when you think about interest rates are
we going to see
nominal negative interest rates in
america
um
i think
we probably already have them right we
already have negative real rights yeah
and we already have negative real rights
but do you think we'll see the actual
negative
rates like you'll literally go and
they'll say the negative rate is you
know negative one percent
uh
when they are ready to just give up
because if if they do that then the
dollars toast
yeah we had a little taste of that
during the 2000 or any crisis remember
there was this talk about we can't break
the buck
the money market funds out there which
are not they're not cash right there's
it's uh short-term debt all money market
funds and there was a threat that they
would
go under a dollar the official rate and
they did everything that was humanly
possible including remember you had tim
geithner and others go in front of
congress and say we need
you know just under a trillion dollars
uh congress said we need to read what
the document is and they said okay look
at it tomorrow market crashed that night
and then they came back and they they
signed it
and um that led to
16 17 trillion in various bailouts and
credit facilities so so i think that
rather than go negative nominal on the
actual rate i mean that just keep going
extraordinary excuse me
i think actually i i realized you could
see it in the
the news basically the the geopolitics
over the past few months is like there
seems to be uh some sort of tension
really building escalating rapidly with
china they'll do nominal rates and
they'll blame china they'll say we had
to do it because of china and they own
all this debt of ours and they own
you know so much of our uh bonds and
stuff like that so they'll say they had
to do this because of china and china
forced their hand you know the the fact
that uh all these chinese companies are
gonna have to de-list from
uh the new york stock exchange and stuff
like that i just think there's like some
sort of building you know the thucydides
trap is real and it's happening and this
is this is the moment they're gonna use
that as an opportunity to say uh we need
nominal rates and if you're a patriot
you'll support this because this has to
be done yeah with the uh with the
promise of uh
you you bite the bullet you're fighting
china yeah it's like war bonds right
they offered them at a lower coupon than
other non-war bonds uh to help fight win
the war right during the during the war
so that could be sold in that way that
in order to be china you need to take a
negative nominal rate on your on your
bonds treasury bonds talk to me about
pension funds and large capital
allocators it seems like they're really
screwed right they've for
years and years and years now applied
kind of a 60 40 type portfolio a lot of
it is kind of cover your asset worse i
don't want to have any sort of career
risks so if i just do what everyone else
is doing then i can't get fired uh and
that has been okay right most of them
are hitting somewhere between you know
five to seven percent their actuarial
rate of return is usually somewhere
seven and a half eight percent but
they're missing the mark uh we just saw
calpers uh which is one of the largest
pension funds in the country decided
they're gonna now start taking on
leverage they're gonna start adding more
uh alternative assets like you just
start seeing some of this stuff and
i don't think they even think that
they're necessarily uh becoming more
conservative or better investors they're
just saying like we have no choice we
have to do this or literally we can't
pay people like how do you read that
first of all i want to say max pretty
much got kicked off stage in uh what was
it 2005 or six when uh he went on stage
with one of the heads of calpers
at the time it was uh 2000 they let you
close yeah yeah
it was at the triple bottom line
investing conference and um
they it was just announced it was like
in um march or april of maybe 2007 or
something like that
2006 and they had just announced that
they bought all these cdos the headlines
look it up from bear stearns and max
said you know why these things are going
to zero so uh and why are you putting
this in these uh your pension funds for
these uh teachers and
you know government workers in in um in
california and uh they refused to have
their you know there was a group photo
afterward and they were like we can't
have max in there but of course
of course bear stearns blew up soon
after that max said it was going to zero
so
but i think one quick thing is that in
terms of the pension stuff i think it's
that's kind of intergenerational because
uh no millennials or zoomers have
pensions right it's just the boomers and
the boomers are trying to reconcile with
reality and the reality is that they've
incurred a huge amount of debt they blew
the legacy that was america they blew
this giant
amazing economy and turned it into trash
exported all our jobs left a hollow out
shell of rust belt and a hundred
thousand annual overdose deaths so
they're the ones that created that and i
think you know fortunately for zoomers
and millennials
they've got bitcoin
yeah yeah and you know the pension funds
you talk they're getting five to seven
percent but how far out on the risk
curve are they going for that they're
going way out on the risk curve you know
10-year treasuries are one and a half
percent so they're they're taking on an
enormous amount of risk and they're
exposed to an enormous amount of risk
and they're going to lose an enormous
amount of money um and that's pretty
clear the
what's really sad about the whole
pension industry and about the savings
industry is that
the
artificial suppression of interest rates
you know the past 10 15 20 years has
effectively moved five trillion dollars
from pension accounts and savings
accounts
into the pockets of speculators it's a
theft right interest rate should have
been allowed to increase long ago they
normalized rates you know if you look at
different schools of thought and
different studies you know you come up
with around five percent would be a
normalized
rate and we kind of fluctuate around
five percent so we've been hovering
around zero for years now uh even and
even though you've got
all kinds of indications of bubbles
forming in everywhere that would require
a response from the central bank to
raise rates uh instead they've lowered
rates
and
they've effectively stolen a lot of
money from these pension accounts they
go into the speculators pockets and then
speculators end up getting more
political power and then they end up
influencing washington to pass laws to
make it easier for them to take money
out of pension accounts you know this is
something el salvador is going to have a
chance to avoid because they're now
going to be writing securities laws and
rewriting securities laws for the first
time in el salvador and they're going to
do so in ways that have go to school
onto problems in the u.s and what's
happened and to avoid all that and based
on built on a bitcoin standard
so all that kind of um influence
peddling market manipulation and this
the pump you know the market
you know you watch our show you know my
show you know us we've been reporting on
this
not only on on the kaiser report but
going back 18 19 years
the amount of manipulation by these
banks and bankers is is ludicrously off
the chart i mean jamie dimon i'm not
going to go on a huge tangent there but
they've paid hundreds of millions of
dollars in fines they were caught
rigging precious metals markets the bank
of england caught rigging libor market
every single market maker and bank
around the world has been caught
manipulating markets stealing money
front-running markets congress is even
uh trading on inside information they
might the level of corruption is
extraordinary and it's all fueled by
that ultra-cheap money that's why they
don't want to raise rates you don't
think nancy pelosi wants higher rates if
she's able to stick her sticky little
fingers in the pie every day and take
some cash out based on insider trading
and artificially cheap credit that's not
where it's going to come from so they're
incentivized to commit fraud if you took
fraud out of the u.s business model
you'd have nothing
joe john do you guys have uh any sort of
like pension plans or or uh outside of
just like your traditional retirements
no i just have retirement accounts
bitcoin yeah i mean yeah i i do think
also uh nick uh badia today he wrote a
picture about like bitcoin is life
insurance as well right and his main
argument was hey normally what you do is
you buy a policy you then pay your
premiums and then at some point in the
future uh somebody pays your loved ones
your family or friends uh future value
for what you purchased up front and uh
that there's some arbitrage there when
you do ultimately die and his argument
was well that's basically what bitcoin
does as well right if you buy the
bitcoin today and you hold it for a long
period of time bitcoin becomes your life
insurance policy in a very unique way
and would you be better off buying the
life insurance and paying the premium or
just buying bitcoin right and allowing
it to appreciate what do you guys think
about that well the insurance industry
is a huge buyer of interest rate
products that the very arbitrage you're
talking about is the basis for how the
insurance company operates their payouts
are going to be less than the aggregate
income from their
um premiums and what they have earning
interest at various treasury bond
markets and i think that one of the
fallouts from the blow up and the global
bond market is going to be the insurance
industry gets blown up as well so there
won't be an insurance industry uh when
you see when these bonds blow up
finally
so i think it's prudent to
seek alternative ways to save for the
future bitcoin obviously offering as
nick points out you can it's a
substitute for life insurance in this
way plus it's an asset you own because
if you weren't around during the 2008
financial crisis as max mentioned it was
breaking the buck and the mutual fund
sector but also it was the insurance
sector which really got bailed out it
was aig and the likes of those that got
bailed out if it if it weren't you know
on the surface everybody thinks okay it
was goldman sachs and was all these uh
jp morgan that were bailed out but
really it was the other side of those
derivatives and the aig so
they could have gone bust overnight um
and that could happen in the next
situation so your life insurance company
whoever has underwritten your life
insurance policy they could go bust
easily yes the counterparties that they
had to bail out you don't get as much
attention i saw the same thing happen in
august in september of 1987. i was
working as a stock broker in new york
and during the crash of 87 and people
talk about black friday where the market
dropped i think 22 percent but on the
following monday the market was set to
open down another 500 points
and it became then they said every
insurance company in america would be
bankrupt insolvent so it was then when
robert rubin
ronald reagan and alan greenspan formed
the
working group on finance which became
known later as the plunge protection
team and that was a seminal moment in
american financial history because for
the first time the federal government
was buying s p futures contracts to bail
out the stock market so free market
capitalism as we knew it kind of died on
that day and that's metastasized and
become
huge so that instead of being
you know part a little fringe aspect to
the markets it has become the tail
wagging the dog it is the market the
government is in there every single day
steering prices moving things around
changing laws really at the behest of
the small code array of insiders and the
free market as we know in america
doesn't exist anymore
is that a uh net positive or net
negative since they started it's a [ __ ]
show that's why we're moving to el
salvador
i'm i'm looking forward to getting out
of this [ __ ] i'm so sick of these
privileged wall street bankers getting
the free handouts and and claiming that
they need more free handouts at the
expense of everybody look at society
it's breaking down 100 000 overdoses
last year
from you know the pharmaceutical
industry oxycontin and the rest uh the
cities are breaking down san francisco
new york chicago
um that's all homicides last year
homicide was the single largest one-year
jump in homicides in any given year uh
in history that's and that's that's
growing that's a plague that america has
a plague of violence and corruption it's
it's an oligarchy uh plagued by violence
and corruption and it's growing
exponentially because of the money
printing that's that's the cause of it
you're you're rewarding the worst in
society it's called a cachistocracy
where it's ruled by the worst
not a meritocracy it's a cachistocracy
and um
it's not gonna get better
anytime soon tell me more about uh what
did you say cactus pakistan i can't
pronounce any words i think it's a greek
word you know and and if you the the
prefix are kaka you know people know
that as [ __ ] right so it's a shitocracy
essentially it's what runs america it's
it's run by the the shittiest most
corrupt evil
sticky-fingered losers uh ever assembled
in one place of governance in washington
dc
and uh the results are in there it's
plain to see look around it looks
terrible it's even driving here from
fort lauderdale it's like going through
i said that i've been marrakesh look
better you know i've been in so-called
third world countries that had better
infrastructure the airports in this
country are go to asia you know go
somewhere else you'll see airports that
are uh very very very different so
anyway the point is this bitcoin
is a relentless optimism it's a vector
out it's the soundest money ever and
here you got a country that's gonna make
it legal tender i've got skills you know
i'm a former banker i'm a bitcoiner uh
we've got a whole history in this space
let's we're gonna move there we're gonna
we're gonna be part of the new world the
new new world are you going to
completely
leave residents in the united states
like in terms of are you going to move
there and get rid of your house and uh i
think north carolina
no we we would keep our house and we
would keep our u.s passport as well
and um
we won't uh stay there for the rainy
season right i'm not big on rainy season
okay i'm probably with you i don't like
the cold or probably rain is lumped in
as well can you talk about just global
adoption of bitcoin right so the
argument against el salvador it's a
relatively small country um but can you
just talk about other countries that can
benefit from this outside of obviously
zimbabwe with hyperinflation what other
countries do you think will be next
right i think in the region that
definitely the word's gone out and
they're looking very closely at it so
um guatemala which is next door uh is
looking at it quite seriously uh all the
other countries in the region they're
gonna see this country's uh
the benefits that will accrue pretty
quickly and they're going to jump onto
it and they all have access to cheap
energy they've got volcano energy in
particular geothermal energy uh so that
that region i think in the next 12 to 18
months also you know in terms of that
region is like um
yes you've had a lot of interference and
it's probably not very easy being a
small country uh so close to the united
states
but
you know the only other alternative that
keeps on being offered is like a very
very left-wing communist sort of um
populist so once they see like the
standard of living and the the situation
for the ordinary person
you know their their situation get
better in el salvador i think that could
inspire some more left-wing progressive
sort of side of the equation
uh across the region so i i hope that
happens because i don't think you know
going back and forth between
you know communism and then uh you know
a u.s backed military
coup sort of situation junta um i think
you know this could be this is plan b
right this is a a way out of that you
know back and forth between the cycle
yeah breaks that cycle
i feel like you two are the perfect
people to talk about this next sensitive
topic which is uh in the middle east
there's a lot of people who i think
recognized
a relationship with the world
superpowers that maybe wasn't so
favorable to their country and so uh
there's many different attempts or uh
strategies as to how to deal with that
right some of them uh thought that maybe
going after the way that oil was priced
would be one strategy other people
thought that being hyper uh defiant was
another strategy some people thought
that being super collaborative was a
strategy uh it usually has not turned
out very well for many of those
countries because it ends up being
violence at the kind of end of the uh
road how do you think about that with
south or central american countries with
something like el salvador which i think
if you asked most people in the world
they'd be like the country has six and a
half million people like they couldn't
you know they probably have a hard time
fighting anybody let alone a superpower
and they don't think of them as like a
violent type attacking country yeah but
bitcoin is like i said it's the the
market for that is 7 billion that's a
total addressable market of
citizens and residents of bitcoin so
look at the middle east [ __ ] show and
that's caused by previous empires
dividing up on along all sorts of lines
you go to beirut and it's like an
amazing place but
yeah there's dividing lines and and like
this religion gets that many
parliamentary seats and that religion
gets that and like it's just an
absurdity that divides people by these
artificial
barriers whereas bitcoin unites
everybody and ends that because it's
we're we're all part of the protocol you
know
no if you have one satoshi you have just
as much power
and say over the protocol as michael
saylor so like it doesn't matter you're
you're on the protocol there's no bully
there's no empire there's no dictator
there's no anybody there's just you on
the protocol yeah also
salvadorians there's 30 percent of
salvadorians live in the united states
there's a huge remittance market so by
adopting a bitcoin standard they're
going to save 400 million dollars a year
right off the get-go by going into
bitcoin mining projected to make a
billion in revenues year one
how how much can he transform this
country in terms of like leapfrogging uh
let's say the united states is near the
top right whether it's the top or top 10
or whatever from a country standpoint
based on a bunch of different metrics
and let's say el salvador is
near the middle of the pack to the
bottom right depending on what metric
you're looking at can he leapfrog into
the top 10 countries in the world well
you can leapfrog onto this new monetary
standard right because you have no money
of your own it's just the us dollar so
they have no control over it anyway it's
just like with africa that they
leapfrogged onto you know mobile
technology because they didn't even
and bank you know uh banking
infrastructure on their mobile phones
they were one of the first there
with things like m-pesa because they
didn't have a legacy banking system so
not having a legacy system often does
allow one to leapfrog so yeah is it
really about leapfrogging or is it more
about stepping away from a falling
collapsing building
and surviving
so right now they've got a dollar in el
salvador it's a dollar standard and the
us dollar is in serious trouble as we
just talked about and the u.s economy is
in serious trouble as we just talked
about so um is it about leapfrogging or
catching up to the us or is it about
stepping aside and letting the us
collapse and not getting hurt badly by
it i think a lot of people the incentive
at this point in bitcoin circles is to
escape the
the controlled demolition of the u.s
empire which is a huge going to be a
huge event in the next 18 to 24 months
but without having to uh jump on uh some
sort of china bandwagon so that's often
like the the paradigm that is set up
over the past few hundred years is like
here's one superpower and it's being
displaced by another superpower and
we've had what 18
thucydides traps over the past several
hundred thousand years or something not
hundred thousand but hundreds or
thousands of years and so
this is a a plan b it's a way out of
that cycle like it break it breaks all
the cycles i think it was michael saylor
that said it
what would it take for you guys to
renounce your citizenship like would
there be like a final straw where you
just like all right like screw this
route
nope nope well we've got too much family
here but also um you know once you're
over a certain net worth anyway it's
almost impossible to renounce u.s
citizenship so uh
maybe if if you know if you had that
just like a couple hundred dollars to
your name it it's possible to do but um
it's kind of difficult but it you know i
think um
you know america is a really rich
country in terms of the resources it has
including the people so we have that
federal system we have that sort of
states rights we have uh
you know we just lived in europe for
over 15 years
and to come from europe which is like a
museum
to america which is super dynamic and
the people are dynamic and you know as
salvadorans by the way like most a lot
of salvadorans are also uh american so
yeah it's just like i don't see myself
not wanting to be here like okay a lot
of people in the whole well i would say
crypto space rather than bitcoin space
moved to puerto rico and you can move to
puerto rico as an american because
they're american and you could go there
and not pay taxes and do all that stuff
but i don't want to you know be
restricted in terms of how much i can
travel where i could travel
staying in america keeping you know my
families here we have friends here like
i don't want to be restricted in terms
of where i can and can't go yeah the
point about states is a really good
point because within the united states
unlike in europe and elsewhere you do
have states rights and autonomy and so
there are states in america that are
becoming very bitcoin friendly texas and
wyoming and florida right so you guys
have kind of come to florida uh in large
part because it's becoming very friendly
to bitcoin so this is a kind of a
variation on this theme you know now
we're looking at different country but
the same thought process like i want to
be where it's bitcoin friendly where i'm
getting some respect because i'm a
bitcoiner um so uh it could be that
texas for example which has already got
ted cruz and some other people or
wyoming with cynthia lummus you know
they actually decide that they're going
to take a firmer position against the
federal government and they're going to
be a safe harbor to bitcoiners and
they're not going to uh thwart
innovation we're not going to tax them
extraordinarily i mean a great uh
thing to look at is what happened with
marijuana laws like i don't i don't
smoke marijuana but i do smell it
everywhere you go in america and it's
just extraordinary right i mean it's
still against the law federally and yet
you could smoke it and buy it and sell
it all over the united states in various
states because they just said you know
to the federal government that's
extraordinary uh first of all the word
marijuana we've been told means you're a
cop yeah you have to say oh really
that's what we've been told so you cop
but but uh second of all is i think
there's two different components to this
right is we've seen places like let's
say colorado i think is the
quintessential example where they went
and they changed the state law so there
was a legislative process over
insurances and they did it because they
got tax revenue and all the benefits
they got but there's also places like
baltimore where there was a district
attorney who said i have no legislative
power whatsoever but i'm just not going
to prosecute these people anymore they
decriminalized it and so i think that
it's harder to decriminalize without the
legislative powers right for something
like this
but i do think that it would be
absolutely fascinating if all of a
sudden you had a state step up and say
you know what we're going to do we're
going to basically say there's
absolutely zero income tax or there's
zero whatever tax maybe the closest
we've seen is kentucky i think changed
some of the
taxation laws for people around
electricity so if you use kentucky power
to mine bitcoin they change your tax
status or tax treatment again that's
more for a corporate entity and it was
just at the state level i don't know
really how it works with the
relationship with the federal level i
mean okay florida got no state or local
tax same thing with texas
right so the states have a lot of power
and puerto rico puerto rico is a very
interesting situation tax wise and it's
still part of the u.s u.s territory et
cetera so the states have a lot of
leeway and i think that as bitcoin as
other countries particularly start to
show what you can do when you have a
bitcoin standard a lot in the states you
might have governors and mayors and
politicians decide that you know we need
to get in on this
ourselves and they can be very active
and proactive in in pursuing that and i
think that's part of the game theory
built into
the genesis block you know it's been
with us since the very very beginning
there's that game theory that's built in
to bitcoin protocol that encourages this
type of
mutually beneficial outcome for all uh
in a decentralized way and that it's uh
the net net is that
we are pushing out the weak fiat money
and even gold you know gold's being
demonetized i think that the numbers are
in on that um so because you've got the
apex predatory you've got bitcoin in
your mind what is the end goal for
bitcoin is it to become the global
reserve currency like where do you see
it ending up in 10 years 20 years 30
years right bitcoin becomes essentially
the global reserve currency because uh
it just pushes everything else out
there's nothing that can compete with it
and people want to use it as money and
as a store of value and that's what
dictates ultimately
the the market it'll be a unit of
account everybody will think in bitcoin
what does this cost me in bitcoin what
does this car cost me in bitcoin what
does this how much bitcoin am i earning
in this job
like even if they have a local currency
that's different that's true what are
the obstacles to get there
the obstacles to get toward hyper
bitcoinization on a global basis
uh are uh the entrenched oligopoly
that is not keen on giving up their
position
and uh the thing about bitcoin is that
it's a peaceful revolution it's not a
violent revolution unlike any other
revolution in the past it's been a
violent revolution with bitcoin it's all
you need to do is adopt and use bitcoin
uh to be part of the revolution and as
the use grows as price goes up
everything that we know about it
and it squeezes out the weak hands it
squeezes out the weaker economies the
weaker minds the weaker and it acts like
a mirror and it exposes people like paul
krugman or somebody like that who's a
public intellectual uh others other
economists who are uh like naseem tele
was an amazing case of someone who had
an incredible reputation and within
three or four months it became
completely trashed
because the bitcoin mirror showed us
that this guy was intellectually
dishonest at some level and it got
crushed by it
um and so this is this is this happens
across the spectrum with other
economists other intellectuals other
monetary theories like stacey was saying
it's an excellent point typically in the
central america it's a choice between
military dictatorship and socialism
and either side of that coin is doesn't
work you know this is the third option
this is the third way this is the vector
out this is the bitcoin way it gets
it demonetizes both it it gets rid of
both it's a preferential way it's kind
of controlled entirely by the
individuals who have that uncomplicated
wealth that private key that can't be
taken away from them and that encourages
a behavior in the community you know i
say you don't change bitcoin bitcoin
changes you and you see that in el
salvador where the president is thinking
big he's thinking in new ways he's
thinking let's bring all these people
here he's getting the benefit of that of
that bitcoin philosophy that bitcoin
thinking
that that comes with it beyond just the
fact that its number go up you see you
see bitcoin changing him you see bitcoin
change michael saylor you see bitcoin
change us you see bitcoin change
everybody so i everybody's on their own
journey
only you can do you you know you can
approach the rabbit hole in any way that
is unique to you but we all end up at
the same place which is hyper
bitcoinization yeah i think that's what
for me the key to bitcoin maximalization
or bitcoin maximalist is that the
recognition that there is this one
point on the horizon that everyone's
kind of going toward
and to deny that is just wasting
everyone's time just understand that
we're all kind of heading into that one
global hyperbolization bitcoin standard
point on the horizon we're on this
pilgrimage together
toward this this this outcome and that's
bitcoin maximalization and for those who
argue against it
i i i'm there everyone's happy to argue
against it but i that no one's made a
compelling case that that what i just
said is not true uh they make very
pedantic cases they make very circular
logical kind of run arounds and trolling
cases that go nowhere
and we've all seen them the fiat world i
think has like a social credit score
mentality so you're kind of brought up
to be very suburban and be very polite
and very nice to somebody just because
they smile at you and uh for me
personally and i can only speak for
myself like that sort of toxic
maximalism just
saves me from having to be nice to
somebody just because i i've known them
for 10 years and now they have a [ __ ]
coin that they you know and it just
helps to like okay i just uh don't
i i how do i get over the fact that i
just want to be polite and say oh hey
that's cool glad for you you know it's
just like it's a weight it's a
self-defense mechanism
maybe
you know some people
are different they they could easily
like not be polite and still not be
toxic you know what i mean but i can't
let me ask uh two questions so one of
the uh
things that happens in the fiat world is
that you have dollars dollars are the
reserve
currency from a medium exchange store
value it's also the unit of account that
people use and the game if you will in
the fiat world is to earn dollars or get
acquired dollars somehow to then take
them invest them
grow in dollar terms and then go back
into dollars right so it's just the
acquisition of more and more and more
dollars yeah when you think of bitcoin
is there a world where you would say
okay we want to acquire bitcoin whether
we're buying it we're earning it however
we acquire it you then invest the
bitcoin into other things whether it's
equities or real estate or whatever with
the hope of acquiring more bitcoin and
going back into bitcoin or is the
thought process the biggest client is
already compounding at an incredible
rate per year over like over 150 correct
and so
anytime you step off bitcoin your risk
profile goes up and it goes up
dramatically
and if you're in any way not even
able to handle managing risk which is
the case for 99.9 of the population out
there are very bad at handling a risk
because it gets very emotional this idea
of i'm going to step out make some money
and then step back in it almost in all
cases doesn't work because you're going
to step out you're going to lose
and then you're going to be in a
situation where now what do i do and
most people like this is the this is
called the gambling industry right this
is las vegas if you go into the a floor
in a las vegas casino and you ask a
hundred people how are they doing and
they'll say i'm winning and you know
that's false they're all losing yep and
that's that's that's the problem is that
the risk reward on bitcoin is so
incredibly good that to step off that uh
bitcoin into anything else is you're
you're bringing on and then a lot of
risk that you don't need to because
you're already compounding at this
incredible rate per year so why even
take on any risk and that went that way
yeah so it's like 170 percent i think
right now compound annual growth rate
overlapping right so why why would you
step off that you know so let's say that
bitcoin continues on this path of hyper
bitcoinization which every d you know
every kind of uh underlying fundamental
every single data point we have seems
like that's the general direction how
long it takes up for debate but that's
where we're going kind of your point
there's this like north star that is the
the culmination point when we get there
the idea would be that bitcoin is quote
stable right one bitcoin equals one
bitcoin and so therefore everything is
priced in bitcoin et cetera
does your opinion change once we get to
that point so right now you're getting
kind of the monetization of bitcoin very
opposite of the demonetization of gold
and so you're getting this priced into
the world the world's trying to figure
out how much is uh a decentralized kind
of transparent central bank with a
programmatic monetary policy that's
literally protected by millions of
people around the world what's that
worth right now the world thinks it's
worth a trillion dollars i think that
everyone in this room thinks it's worth
way more than that in the future but
we'll see how that happens do we reach a
point where there's stability and then
you have to go back to the thinking of
investing bitcoin to earn more bitcoin
no okay because
the end game on bitcoin is something
very very interesting very remarkable
and if you notice pomp you know you and
i have been in this for a while
that there is a whole school now bitcoin
philosophy and bitcoin
kind of um
you know deep thinking that that that
people like robert breedlove and others
get into it uh michael saylor touches on
it
i think that where we're heading here is
where we start to really
have a different thought about what is
wealth and what is
my purpose here on planet earth and
where the idea of that pursuit
of wealth and that constant calculation
that people are making this is risk this
is not risk i get a little bit here i
get a little bit there i got my
portfolio got my multiple income streams
i got this going on i think that that
there's a fundamental shift because
you're monetizing people's
better nature in and you're coming out
of a period many many thousand year
period where we're monetizing people's
worst aspects people's greed
has been transformed by bitcoin into
altruism into something that's mutually
beneficial for everyone and when you
have that happen in society the people
are going to step out and just say you
know what i just want to stay here play
my flute raise a garden of zucchinis and
you know i'm not i'm just want to be me
i just want to be cosmically uh one with
who i am as a human being and i want to
look at the stars and i just i don't you
just leave me alone um i think that
that's the outcome when toward a hyper
bitcoinization of
that that when you have that moment of
almost as a species without getting too
off the range here but almost as a
species it's almost like an evolutionary
step change where we
finally put down the childish toy
of
our egos and our need to
get more and more and more
and and we join
we join our into a more of a communal
uh high that's the time preference the
shift in time preference that's that's
that's what the rabbit hole is all about
so so the skills that people have that
are thinking you know i have skills in
hustling i have skills as an
entrepreneur there's a bitcoin thread of
thought that says that no matter what i
do bitcoin's going to keep going up
anyway where am i ever going to be able
to use my skills and the answer is no
you won't you're good we're all going to
go to a place where people are
essentially going to be in a different
completely different place now obviously
there's no way to the only way we can
know this is going to happen is to
actually lift through and see if it's
going to happen and it what's the timing
on this and it all depends on how fast
the dollar collapses i think that's the
linchpin to the whole
the whole puzzle you know you need the
dollar to really collapse to move us
beyond everything you associate with the
dollar in the post-world war two global
hegemony and the the the model of hyper
consumption you know 70 percent of the
u.s economy's consumption and yet also
you have incredibly high rates of
prozac and xanax and oxycontin and
stress and disorder and dysfunction
right it's not a happy society people
generally are miserable i think it's
going to bring out the best in us though
and i think i don't know if kelly said
it first or he said it for about us like
if we were the ones that said it first
and then so it's hard to remember where
it all began but the best minds
in the world are being attracted to
bitcoin and i think you're going to have
i think we're in the middle of the early
days of a renaissance 2.0 and you know
just look at history to see what
happened with renaissance 1.0
and
you know medici wasn't exactly a high
time preference sort of guy like why
how how did we have in one little
city
state
how did we have
da vinci michelangelo botticelli how did
we have all those people in one spot
like why was medici financing them was
he like hoping to flip it to the next uh
gold dealer you know no he was uh
thinking
we're talking about medici today because
he financed those guys because he
he helped pay for that like
if he had just been some rich dude in
history
like are we going to talk about elon
musk in 100 500 years it depends on what
he decides to do with his wealth right
think about that your question in terms
of a relationship you know you're
married
you just are getting married
yup i'm single
you'll soon be married right so
in a marriage you realize that
you know you don't compete with each
other essentially you are one you know
and you are
everything that goes on in the marriage
and that's kind of like globally we all
of all society could be having that
experience where we're all essentially
expressing
a love on a more of a love
um
um a protocol than than one right now
which is based certainly our economy is
50 cents of every dollar goes into the
pentagon it's a war-based economy the
fiat money as paul krugman at the new
york times said is backed by men with
guns that's what backs the u.s dollar is
violence and that's true of all fiat
money it has been for hundreds of years
so love itself is not monetized love is
not in it's not as put as a premium in
our lives in that way imagine if if it's
flipped if if hatred and war and
violence are demonetized and they get
pushed down
down to the bottom of the emotional
speed rack and love faith and
and and understanding and peace are
moved up you're going to have a
completely different society so that
that's my answer to your question is
that the question is not
do we at that time is there going to be
a period where we're out there trying to
aggregate more bitcoin because we've
achieved uh parity um
i think the answer is no because we're
going to be very very different as a
species and as as people john what
questions do you have can you both talk
about your thoughts around just the us
government holding bitcoin all the
regulations that's going on currently
and like does that stifle innovation
does not can you just give me your
thoughts around all that the u.s
government stupidly stole their bitcoin
right they had ross ross albrecht's
bitcoin they sold it they sold it to tim
tim draper you know over in silicon
valley right they've been sellers of
bitcoin stupidly um they they're stupid
the chinese government is stupid for
kicking out the miners and um they don't
they don't you know bitcoin avoids
narcissistic kleptocrats and the u.s
china countries that have mental
problems uh it doesn't go well uh so it
will the u.s change i think what we've
said is that you've got the states have
the ability to
reformulate a course of action and take
on the federal government so that's
where it's going to come from texas
wyoming florida are leading so um maybe
the texas uh teachers pension fund or
something like that or the texas general
municipality pension fund says we're
going to put a bitcoin position that
starts a ripple effect uh for all over
from state to state uh you could see
that happening but at the federal level
i don't see it happening because uh for
the reasons you know that i just said
the the other piece of this uh is we
recently had um uh whit gibbs coming
from compass mining and he
i don't know if he meant to say it or uh
slipped and said that the united states
government was mining bitcoin in the
middle of the country
let's say that there's a 50 50
probability whether that's happening or
not
what is the us's play if you were the
president of the united states and you
said okay here's a situation i'm facing
currently we've talked about that and
then here's this new technology
do you
shut down the federal reserve and go buy
a bunch of bitcoin do you start mining
do you just make the rules uh a little
bit more relaxed so that you can
incentivize uh entrepreneurs and
innovators like how do you think about
like
what should they do
michael saylor the fed chairman
or the treasury secretary why and say um
take the game book the the playbook user
using over a microstrategy and apply to
the federal government please and do it
fast so that we don't get
disintermediated out of the 21st century
because at this rate we're going to be
uh blown out of the water by these
smaller more nimble more agile smarter
bitcoin countries i think i think they
don't care about i think you know
they're in the mindset of we have the us
treasuries and the us dollar and we're
dominant then but i it makes sense
geopolitically that they would be mining
bitcoin just as probably all many
nations are mining bitcoin in order to
move
secretly
around the internet and around the globe
because it's it's you know untraceable
money and you don't need a 747 to move
your gold around and you can just
you know finance projects dark you know
black ops you know with uh bitcoin so i
think that's probably if if they're
mining bitcoin that's probably what
they're doing not necessarily to
stockpile like any uh store of value
plus after if somebody saw me oh the
federal government's mining bitcoin in
the middle of america somewhere i'd have
to ask well
is it the same federal government that
is operating outside of the uh
democratic process that gave us all
kinds of political problems in the last
five 10 20 years i mean if they are
mining it is are we going to be sharing
in that bounty or are they going to
steal no no i mean they could be using
our resources to go my bitcoin and then
they could go leave the country
right so i mean these guys are like i
said they're the corruption is uh it's
on a scale that's off the charts so why
would i trust them for a one second i do
know for
a fact because a person who worked at
the organization told me uh that in
let's call it 2012 2013 one of the
federal law enforcement agencies uh they
wanted to conduct uh cryptocurrency
related uh investigations and as part of
that uh they wanted to do some
undercover type work uh they
either did not believe they could get
approved or
went for the approval and got denied for
a budget approval to purchase bitcoin so
instead they said well they always give
us approval for computers and so they
went ahead and they put in a budget
approval for
mining equipment and they ended up
mining bitcoin now one they were able to
actually get their hands on bitcoin two
was virgin bitcoin so you couldn't trace
it etc and then that was used for uh
investigations now
i don't want to uh exaggerate in terms
of my guess is that that was a very
small amount right and i don't think
that people would count that as like the
government is holding bitcoin right i
think when we talk about that we're
talking about it in terms of it's on you
know treasury federal reserve this is
part of our uh our uh kind of national
strategy
outside of just that of putting michael
saylor or somebody like that to almost
pull off a speculative attack
what else would you do he sees miners in
texas
you might seize the miners hell yeah
that's probably what they're thinking
about that's the easiest way for the u.s
government to get into bitcoin
businesses go down to those huge
operations that are in texas now and
seize them like they stole they took the
gold in the in the 30s right they seized
everyone's gold the federal government
could seize all those miners in texas
that could trigger a serious conflict
with the state of texas so i was just
going to ask if they were to go because
that's a pretty bold well
the government under eminent domain uh
you know under under the auspices of
national security can do
anything they want to do they may take
your shoes off at the airport yeah right
and again it's getting worse and worse
and people and people's rights are being
more and more abused so they they would
go down that would be from in my view
that would be the easiest way for the
federal government to get in the game
pretty fast
that's what i mean like our guests our
frequent guests that we've had on kaiser
report jim rickards who works with the
cia war gaming
war and he always said to us on kaiser
report that the u.s government would
seize all of the gold
held on behalf of other nations so we
hold a lot of gold
of our own the united states gold but we
also own gold we hold gold for other
nations afghanistan right well yeah but
nations like germany uh correct yeah i'm
just saying they just our allies that we
would seize their goals they just
reneged on the on the afghani gold yeah
yeah the afghans basically uh whatever
whoever you want to say is in power now
right depending on if it's the official
run official basically said give us our
money back and they said when i give it
to you because we don't know who who's
in charge yeah so that's what they would
do that's
the similar mindset would happen with um
whatever
you know bitcoin miners that make sense
like we've already seen with china what
they what they're thinking how they're
operating and i think it's a do you know
this
thucydides trap this relationship
between the us and china the creditor
and debtor
nation going forward is what to look at
for what we might do yeah it is um
it's fascinating to think about uh for
them to get into the game in any
material way both of you immediately
jump to uh them doing something that
most people would argue it was a
violation of some kind of right and
there's ways that they could position it
there's ways that they could uh talk
about it you know i go all the way back
to enhanced interrogation techniques
right as uh as kind of an example
outside the united states then obviously
we have things like tsa et cetera inside
the united states uh
if we start to uh push further into this
stuff we just saw today new york city uh
they now are going to have a couple of
different things i do not want to for
the uh enjoyment of everyone at home
talk about the specific public health
crisis and the validity of it or else we
will find ourselves not on youtube
anymore uh but
which by the way is absurd that we have
to talk about exactly but
uh in new york city you now if you are
between the ages of five years old and
11 got to get the uh get the jab to go
into a restaurant and also if you are a
private business the city is now making
it a legal requirement for you to
mandate your private employees to go
ahead and do it as well uh
does that all play into this right and
i'm using that as one specific example
just because in the news today but how
do you think about some of the
encroachments uh in other areas that
have nothing to do with money or uh
finance or bitcoin but better has a lot
to do with money and money printing
earlier is that because they're not
going to stop printing money they need
to lock everyone down to stop them from
rising up and with the pitchforks and
going after the entrenched oligarchs
right so they've got to lock them up
it's a prison it's an open prison i mean
it works in saudi arabia it works in
gaza it works in other countries around
the world they have open prisons that
they run and uh you can't leave or well
you know we're we have open prisons in
america right now it's called the uh
reservation system if you ever been in
north dakota and the dakotas and up in
those areas you've got the native
population are on
living in open-air prisons right so um
now we have that model being adopted
across the board i think it's a failure
of consensus i think you see
um the elite
uh have given up they can't persuade the
population and i think you see that i
think especially since 2016 since trump
was elected
i think you see
something's going on with the elite
they've literally lost their mind and
they have a real contempt from the
majority of the population the
deplorables who uh didn't go to
university who live in the middle of
america who aren't working in the
creative industries in los angeles san
francisco and new york i think there's
there's a
they're projecting a lot and i think
they fear the people and i think a lot
of this lockdown mentality and you see
on twitter just go on the blue check
twitter
sorry not you but
but the fact that you know there's so
many there's so many like demanding like
let them die let's uh don't treat
anybody who hasn't been vaccinated don't
treat them and it's like that's a real
sick mind that they have that there's
something going on yeah it's like alec
baldwin he said on tv that he cocked the
gun he pointed it he released the hammer
the bullet left a gun and killed the
woman but he has no idea how she died
true
that's that's that's that's literally
what he said is that really what he said
did george stuff it off listen to abc
news it's a sickness and then he deleted
his twitter account and everything else
it was like [ __ ]
but that's that's jamie dimon he's like
we printed trillions and trillions of
dollars now people are dying from the
inflation how did that happen yeah you
bring the money even even worse even
worse than that this this is
we had a field day with uh one day where
uh a reporter which by the way you get
kudos i don't know who the reporter was
but in a very one-off case somebody
asked a hard question and said you know
how do you think about wealth inequality
uh based on all the money printing
and i you couldn't make this up if you
try but he literally said something like
well no one's come into my office and
told me that they uh that there's a uh
that they're suffering from wealth
inequality
yeah and we so we pulled it up we
explained where his office is and how do
you even get to the office right
like so okay so you're only gonna
believe it if somebody tells you it
right but you as the person who's
responsible for this stuff and so again
even if you say all right we'll give you
the benefit of the doubters the slip of
the tongue like you didn't mean it
specifically like that which
questionable uh
i do wonder how much of this is
intentional versus like we give uh folks
in positions of power and influence too
much credit like they actually don't
know this right all the people were
saying inflation was not going to happen
how many of them actually believed that
i think it's a higher percentage than we
probably think really did not believe
inflation was going to go higher i think
they they are flailing i i think they uh
you know a lot of the individuals are
probably trying to do something to stave
off
with bad things
but i think all the data if you just
look at the data if you look at their
data from the fiat world if you look at
the deaths of despair i think that's one
of the number one indicators that
there's been an utter and complete
collapse in the institutions governing
this fiat world you saw the same the
last time you saw this in peacetime was
and the soviet union collapsed and
okay communism is [ __ ] but the fact is
that their state collapsed and you saw
the result in the mass deaths of despair
a lot of alcohol overdose deaths now we
have the same thing we have a declining
life expectancy that's never happened in
peace time so how did that happen what
are the what's what's causing those
deaths of despair and i think it's also
the collapse of the governance model of
our fiat world my uh
my one thing last year during the
lockdowns in new york city uh and you
know uh i'm assuming that hopefully you
two are similar to uh planet and i and
that sometimes i put tweets into the
machine and i'm ready to hit tweet and i
get like a slap on the hands like hey
don't tweet that
i do this all the time
something told me that max may be uh
maybe very similar right but uh one of
the ones that got up uh past the
approval process
was
you're telling me that we have
entrepreneurs uh and small business
owners who literally make up 50 of jobs
in america they can't run their business
but you can go buy alcohol and get
hammered right and you start to there's
arguments around like there's a taxation
component to it right versus uh there's
a literally a public health component of
like if alcoholics aren't allowed to go
get alcohol then there could be even
worse like whatever the reason is you
start to think about like okay that's
weird then you look at like wait a
minute you're telling me it's easier for
me to go literally gamble on the lottery
than it is for me to invest in a private
business right for some people in
america like okay that's weird and you
just go down the line and you don't know
how much of it is like just outright
hypocrisy versus like somebody was
optimizing for a good intention and just
came up with a really stupid rule right
and i think that what we saw with uh uh
with the public health crisis was that
like it exposed all this stuff right and
you just saw it like in such black and
white terms of like
even to the point where the cdc changed
definitions of words on their website
and you're just like it's
totalitarianism is anybody talking about
this like
that's a classic read
you know orwellian gets overused but
look at orwell and what he described
what he saw in the 20s 30s and leading
up to world war ii
is the totalitarianism and that changing
history rewriting history changing
meaning of words
how many of your friends in new york
city all your very wealthy friends their
kids went to school the whole time right
none of the private schools ever shut
down this whole time
all the poor kids none of them have been
going to school for two years algebra is
illegal in california exactly
because they changed why did they change
that definition because they knew what
their consequences their actions are
they knew what they're doing they know
what they're setting up so they're
setting up a situation whereby they
don't want to they don't want a french
revolution an american revolution on
their hands so they're going to change
the words it's like okay yeah
you have no talent at all anymore or no
because we uh
you stayed home sitting at home for the
last two years uh you know i think it's
a i think as part i i think they
understand the consequences of their bad
decisions and i think they're trying to
um find a like all this sjw stuff is a
way for them to try to uh you know kill
me last sort of thing of a revolution
last thing i want to talk about is uh
let's say that all of the conspiracy
theorists right whichever the really
really severe ones all the way to the
ones who are just kind of the
watered-down version uh who appeared to
not only be uh conspiracy theorists as
one label but actually they were just
early right to a lot of this stuff uh
it's another label um
if they're right about majority of this
do we see states like texas and florida
leave like do do we get to the point
where it's literally because it feels
like right now right if i had to put an
over generalized uh uh kind of
mechanism or analysis
new york city san francisco and even la
to some point there was a couple of
people who left in the beginning of you
know kind of q2 of 2020. then by q3
there's a little more q4 more
it broke wide open in january of this
year and in i can speak for miami
specifically uh there was a big question
is over the summer were people gonna
leave it's hot you know all these things
not only did people not leave maybe they
left for a week or two for vacation but
they came back
but now there's even larger influx and
you know the joke is that like the
technology industry invaded art basel
right and so like
if we continue to see the flows where
literally california and new york lost
uh i think it's congressional seats yeah
legislative seats right because they
lost so much in population yeah do we
get like a state's level
maybe not conflict but just like
disagreement to the point where they say
look like we don't want to play by your
rules anymore
the woke refugees the problem is that
our
political leaders are really really
really old like they're the national
level federal level they're like some of
these people have been in power for 50
years and all they've known is from the
very early days of you know when the u.s
dollar started in 1971 they've been in
on that they they don't know where we
are now and i i think maybe on the
state's levels is where you're going to
see you have younger leaders on a state
level and
like dynamic mayors and stuff like that
i think where
it's the only natural response to uh
you know and the entropy at the top on a
very federal level
one other piece that i'm interested in
is as people move from california let's
say to miami or austin or whatever uh do
the politics follow
right so this whole idea of like the
woke revolution the one thing i like
about miami uh is
i don't know what percentage of the
population is from south or central
america but like they've seen all this
before yeah right and the first people
to basically like no uh uh you're not
gonna do that to me again right are
people who come from south central
america we've seen the dictator playbook
the socialist playbook et cetera uh and
it feels like there's a different
culture to some degree of like the
acceptance whereas in new york city i
mean they they literally could probably
tell you you have to go outside every
day at four o'clock and like you know
bow down to the mayor and 50 of the
population probably would do it like
legitimately they would be like oh okay
and that that will save me like where do
i stand one thing i want to say is that
the ac the air conditioning in miami is
turned up way higher than in austin are
you cold right now yes
i'm free freezing keep it cold because
of the lights
it's so cold in miami we have a blanket
somewhere uh because my brothers usually
wear it
yeah throw it to her great there you go
all right max you got anything else uh
you want people to know before uh before
we wrap up
yeah on my way here you know we stopped
yeah he's got a whole list of notes
we stopped at a gas station and you know
it's incredible because you know as i
was saying things have dilapidated a lot
and i want to use the restroom
and um
you know there in the restroom
shockingly it was one what you call one
of these glory holes
there's a hole in the wall what's going
on you know and you know you
you test you interact with it
and on the other side with peter schiff
[Music]
and i couldn't believe it i'm like he's
come to this
that was too good of a story that was
too good max when did you tell peter
shift about bitcoin there's there there
is controversy about it that's not
controversy about it he himself went on
fox business news and said max told me
about bitcoin at ten dollars
okay so he said it so he changed his
mind well
he he is a guy who's very unfamiliar
with the truth that's not his primary
currency of cheating do you still own
any gold do i i've used this collateral
to borrow money to buy more bitcoin yeah
but that's about the only i still own
gold you still own gold what had i just
i keep it for entertainment value i
think it it makes you know it it puts me
in a pleb position people can make fun
of me and i like to have ways for can
you talk about just what else you guys
have your portfolios just
it's almost like it's becoming all
bitcoins it's just all bitcoin and our
and our love
i mean i don't know but some of the
miners because the bitcoin miners are
interesting as a micro strategy
because i think he's going to do like
why is he stockpiling why is michael's
strategy why all this bitcoin right
they're gonna have to use it in a for
the renaissance 2.0 it's going to be the
pristine collateral i think he's going
to do interesting things because i don't
think he's just going to let it sit
there the volcano bonds in el salvador
six and a half percent coupon
it's got a five-year locker on the i'm
definitely going to be we'll buy some
just for you know outside of the system
just to be first like it's um
you know just be first there but that's
a great it's a great six and a half
percent so you're beating inflation and
you've got a five-year lock up on the
half the proceeds go into bitcoin so you
get an upside on the bitcoin the other
half goes into infrastructure including
building out the mining facilities and
uh of the volcanoes et cetera you think
it's a hundred grand to to get the
citizenship uh citizenship last i saw
was underground but they're pricing you
can you can get involved for as little
as a hundred dollars you know the pop i
think that this country i believe last i
checked they've got approximately 20
billion in debt i think that they can be
debt-free in the next 10 years
by selling uh these volcano bonds you
yourself i saw on twitter believe that
these will be oversubscribed and i agree
with you on that i mean this is a
fantastic piece of paper and so they
could sell 10 20 billion in a world with
a quadrillion dollars in derivatives out
there uh and people desperate for yield
well people people saw the micro
strategy bots i think they outperformed
every other bond on wall street right
you're going to see that on the
sovereign level yeah this ends up so
they're going to raise a lot of billions
of dollars they're going to retire all
that debt they're going to get rid of
the imf they're going to be they're
going to write their own ticket outside
of the influence of fiat money imf us
dollar and
it's a great country with great people
great resources and so this is uh this
is going to catch like fire all over the
region and the best minds in the world
the best minds are you guys going to go
to bitcoin city specifically or
somewhere else no it's not there yet
it's just yeah
is going to be more east it's going to
be uh
closer to uh the eastern coast of the
country max and i are going to set up
our own pupusa stand that's right we'll
be selling papooses and
and uh living the life baby you know i
may come and uh i'll bring my brothers
and we'll do a little surfing but the
only problem is that joe's not very
athletic
[Music]
i mean we gave you a congratulations at
the beginning of the show we can't let
you have all the fun you're you're just
trying to make up for the joke i made
before we went on air what was that that
was a good one oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i asked you about it he said the same
thing you heard his response he said the
saint louis rams are going to win
i will say that uh we were with some
people from st louis one time and the
room got kind of like quiet and then all
of a sudden john out of nowhere just
hits him with the so you guys mad that
the rams moved
i asked if they were still rams fans
that's a good question all right ladies
and gentlemen thank you guys so much for
uh for tuning in max stacy thank you
guys for uh for coming here i know that
uh you got a bunch of different stuff
you could be doing with your time joe
john you guys got any uh any other
questions yeah thanks for coming on guys
no comments appreciate it john you gonna
tell max what you tell everyone to do oh
pay off your credit card and go go
follow max on twitter if you don't
already
definitely good advice
you should like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel we'll see you
guys tomorrow
[Music]
you